bonjour à tous merci d'avoir choisi de
regarder cette vidéo mais au fait est ce
que vous êtes certain d'avoir vraiment
choisi de la regarder
vous croyez pas que c'est juste une
série de réactions chimiques dans votre
cerveau qui vous ont fait cliquer
aujourd'hui on va se demander si le
libre arbitre existe vraiment
la plupart des gens estiment qu'ils sont
doués libre arbitre c'est à dire qu'ils
ont la capacité de choisir et décider
librement leurs actes sauf que ça fait
maintenant quelques dizaines d'années
qui a des expériences de neurosciences
qui remettent assez sérieusement en
question cette idée de libre arbitre au
point que certains en sont venus
carrément à penser que le libre arbitre
ça n'existe pas c'est juste une illusion
la première de ces expériences elle a eu
lieu dans les années 80 elle a été faite
par un neuroscientifique américain qui
s'appelle benjamin libère ce café libet
c'est qu'il a pris des sujets il les a
tranquillement installé sur un fauteuil
confortablement et il leur attaché un
petit capteur sur le doigt et il leur a
dit de bouger le doigt quand il voulait
quand ça les chantait et en même temps
qu'il faisait ça il faisait défiler
devant eux une trotteuse qui tournait
assez rapidement un peu comme celle ci
et il demandait aux gens de repérer où
se trouvait la trotteuse au moment où il
prenait la décision de bouger leurs
doigts et donc grâce à ce petit
dispositif livré pouvait savoir quand
est ce que les gens avaient décidé de
bouger et grâce aux capteurs quand est
ce qu effectivement il avait bougé et ce
qu'a pu constater libe c'est que la
décision de bouger ce produit environ
200 millisecondes avant le nouveau à
priori a absolument rien de choquant à
sahin
la décision se produit avant de bouger
il ya un petit temps de latence qui peut
être liée au fait que l'information
voyage dans les nerfs ou peut-être les
muscles doivent se mettre en route
et ce petit temps de latence il est de
200 millisecondes sauf qu'en même temps
libéré faisait à ses sujets un
électroencéphalogramme donc un
électroencéphalogramme ça consiste à
placer des électrodes sur la tête du
sujet et à mesurer l'activité électrique
de leur cerveau et notamment libère
mesure est un signal qu'on appelle le
potentiel de préparation motrices c'est
un signal électrique qui est connu pour
préparer les mouvements et ce qu'a
constaté libet c'est que le signal
commencé à s'élever avant le mouvement
et puis retomber à peu près au moment du
mouvement sauf que si vous regardez bien
cette courbe vous voyez que le signal
commencent à s'élever si 100
millisecondes avant le mouvement et je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure la décision
de bouger elle se produit 200
millisecondes
mouvement ça veut dire que l'activité
électrique dans le cerveau qui prépare
le mouvement elle commence 400
millisecondes avant la décision de
bouger alors cette expérience l air très
perturbante
elle semble nous dire que notre cerveau
commence à initier nos actions bien
avant qu'on ait décidé de les faire dans
ces conditions je vois pas comment je
pourrais avoir un libre arbitre ainsi
quand je décide de bouger le doigt en
fait mon cerveau a déjà décidé depuis
400 millisecondes que j'allais bouger le
doigt tout ça sans me dire que le libre
arbitre est effectivement juste une
illusion
alors quand on y réfléchit un peu plus
calmement on se dit que finalement cette
expérience allait peut-être pas si
choquant ce qu'elle nous dit c'est que
dans tout processus de décision bah il
ya une part inconsciente ça quelque part
c'est pas complètement nouveau on sait
très bien qu'il ya tout un tas
d'activités de la vie de tous les jours
où les décisions se prennent de manière
assez largement inconsciente
quand vous conduisez une voiture par
exemple ou si vous faites un match de
badminton ou que vous jouez une étude de
chopin tous vos mouvements sont pas
consciemment décider l'autre raison qui
fait que l'expérience de libé elle est
peut-être pas assez inquiétante que ça
c'est qu'on est quand même en train de
parler d'une décision qui est très très
rudimentaire bouger un doigt c'est quand
même très simpliste par rapport même aux
décisions qu'on peut prendre dans la vie
de tous les jours je parle même pas des
grandes décisions comme de choisir un
métier choisir un conjoint ou choisir un
nouveau téléphone portable
sauf que il ya quelques années il ya des
chercheurs qui ont fait une variante de
l'expérience de libet qui pour le coup
commence à être vraiment inquiétante
en fait dans cette variante ils ont
utilisé une irm donc vous savez une irm
c'est ce gros appareil qui permet de
scanner votre cerveau est utilisé d'une
certaine manière qui permet de
visualiser notamment quelles sont les
zones du cerveau qui s'activent
ça se fait en fait en observant les
afflux sanguin donc dans l'expérience
dont on parle les chercheurs ont utilisé
l'irm pour faire une variante de
l'expérience de l'idée ils ont placé les
sujets dans l'irm comme dans
l'expérience de libet ils leur ont
demandé de boue
j'ai le doigt au moment où il le voulait
sauf qu'il leur laisser la liberté de
choisir s'il voulait bouger la main
droite ou la main gauche et ce qu'ils
ont constaté c'est que bon déjà il y
avait une activité cérébrale en irm qui
précédait parfois de plusieurs secondes
le mouvement mais qu'en plus cette
activité cérébrale permettait de prédire
si c'était la main droite ou la main
gauche qui allait bouger alors ces
conditions je vois pas comment on peut
dire que le libre arbitre existe si
avant même que j'ai décidé de bouger
le type qui a gardé les rênes il sait
quand je vais bouger et il sait si je
vais bouger la main droite ou la main
gauche ce résultat il faut quand même
relativiser parce que la prédiction est
quand même loin d'être parfaite ça
marche que dans 60 % des cas
mais d'un autre côté il faut savoir
qu'une irm c'est pas non plus un
appareil de mesure extrêmement précis et
on peut s'imaginer qu'on obtiendrait des
résultats bien meilleurs si on utilisait
par exemple des électrodes implantées
dans le cerveau
je sais pas vous mais moi ces
expériences pour l'instant elle
m'empêche pas trop de dormir mais quand
même je peux pas m'empêcher de penser qu
est ce qui se passerait si les
techniques de mesure devenait de plus en
plus sophistiqués et si les résultats
devenaient de plus en plus précis
imaginez par exemple je vous dis vous
venez de gagner deux semaines de
vacances je vais vous montrer la liste
des destinations possibles mais avant ça
je vous mets un casque sur la tête qui
va regarder ce qui se passe dans votre
cerveau alors voilà je vous montre la
liste des destinations la voilà
et maintenant imaginez qu'à peine vous
ayez fini de lire la dernière ligne
le casque vous dise ah vous avez choisi
le trekking au népal
excellent choix je sais pas vous mais
moi ça me perturbe ray un bon on en est
pas encore là mais qu'ici ça va pas
venir un jour alors si ces expériences
vous inquiète sachez quand même
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas vraiment de
consensus entre les spécialistes sur
quelle est la bonne manière de les
interpréter et notamment les philosophes
et les neuroscientifiques sont pas
forcément toujours d'accord sur qu'est
ce qu'il faut en conclure
mais c'est quand même assez intéressant
de regarder quels sont les différents
camps en présence
donc il ya certaines personnes qu'on
appelle les déterministe dur cela ce
sont ceux qui pensent que les lois de la
nature sont déterministe notre cerveau
obéit aux lois de la nature et donc
toutes nos actions toutes nos décisions
c'est juste la conséquence de réactions
chimiques qui se produisent dans notre
cerveau qui peuvent dépendre de nos
perceptions de nos gènes de notre
environnement mais que en définitive il
n'y a absolument aucune notion de libre
arbitre là dedans tout est déterminé et
donc tout se passe comme si on était des
robots fait de chair et d'os mais que le
libre arbitre ne soit qu'une illusion
alors quand même comme le faisait
malicieusement remarquer je crois que
c'était aux kings même ceux qui pensent
que tout est déterminé davance il
regarde quand même à droite et à gauche
avant de traverser la rue la plupart des
gens normaux pense que le libre arbitre
existe quand même
ok ils reconnaissent qu'il ya des
réactions chimiques dans notre cerveau
qu'on ait influencé par nos gènes nos
perceptions notre environnement mais que
en définitive on peut quand même agir
sur tout ça avec notre volonté
cette vision là elle n'est pas très
différente de celle que proposait déjà
des cartes il ya plusieurs siècles
vous savez des cartes disait le monde se
divise en deux catégories
c'est ce qu'on appelle le dualisme il ya
le monde matériel auquel appartient le
corps et qui obéit aux lois de la nature
qui éventuellement son déterministe et
il ya le monde spirituel auquel
appartient l'esprit et l'esprit peut
agir sur le corps alors cette vision là
elle est très rassurante parce qu'elle
permet de sauver l'idée du libre arbitre
en même temps
faut bien reconnaître que c'est quand
même cette vision là qui est le plus
attaqués par les expériences de libet et
consorts et puis il faut savoir que le
dualisme aujourd'hui et quand même pas
très populaire parce qu'il pose plein
plein de problèmes philosophiques et
donc chez les gens qui sont un peu
spécialiste de la question
il n'y a pas grand monde qui pense que
cette vision là puissent être correct
alors il existe une troisième position
un peu intermédiaire qu'on appelle le
compas tbilissi
c'est les gens qui pensent que le
déterminisme et le libre arbitre sont
compatibles en fait ce qu'ils disent
c'est que oui effectivement nos actions
dépendent de réactions chimiques dans
notre cerveau qui dépendent de nos gènes
de nos perceptions etc
mais en définitive c'est quand même
notre cerveau qui détermine nos actions
voilà ma cape laissa libre à m
je sais pas vous mais moi cette position
là j'ai un peu l'impression que c'est
riche et espère que ont redéfini ce
qu'on appelle le libre arbitre juste
pour sauver l'idée qu' on a un libre
arbitre
bon en même temps font un peu comprendre
les gens qui pensent ça parce que si
demain tout le monde était convaincu que
le libre arbitre existe pas il pourra y
avoir des conséquences sociétales qui
serait assez catastrophique
aujourd'hui tout notre système de
justice est basé sur l'idée de
responsabilité individuelle
c'est à dire que si je commets un crime
on va pouvoir me juger et éventuellement
de condamner parce que je suis
responsable de ce que j'ai fait c'est à
dire que j'avais la possibilité de ne
pas le faire j'aurais pu faire autrement
sauf que si demain on dit le libre
arbitre existe pas comment vous voulez
me dire que j'avais la possibilité de
faire autrement
sans compter que si demain tout le monde
devient convaincu que le libre arbitre
existe palais il ya un petit risque que
les gens se mettent à faire n'importe
quoi par exemple quelques années il ya
une étude qui a montré que les gens qui
ne croyaient pas au libre arbitre et des
plus enclins à tricher que les autres
donc vous voyez qu'en définitive
l'important c'est pas tellement de
savoir si libre arbitre existe ou pas
c'est surtout il faut que tout le monde
soit convaincu qu'il existe alors quand
même la prochaine fois que vous êtes
pris en excès de vitesse je vous
déconseille d'essayer de dire aux flics
que non non vous n'y êtes pour rien
c'est juste une série de réactions
chimiques dans votre cerveau qui vous
ont fait appuyer sur la [ __ ]
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle
vous a plu vous pouvez exercer votre
libre arbitre et la partager vous pouvez
aussi vous abonner à la chaîne et me
retrouver sur facebook et sur twitter
on pouvait aussi me lire sur un blog qui
s'appelle science étonnante
à bientôt